elgin ring ps5 saves are being lost
steam deck 2 is in motion and more
el dinnering is available now and it's
one of the best reviewed games of all
time building on from software's souls
formula with an open world mounted
combat and more however the game has
some technical issues to iron out and
publisher bandai namco has outlined what
it's looking to fix in a message posted
today bandai namco said there were
several main items to be revised in
eldon ring primarily in the pc version
this includes an issue with the mouse
sensitivity being too high as well as an
anti-cheat software not loading when
starting the game frame rate issues have
also been reported and bandai namco
recommends updating video card drivers
to improve performance on ps5 save data
can be lost if the ps5 shuts off before
closing the game either when it was
fully powered or in rest mode so if you
were using rest mode as an artificial
pause button you may want to reconsider
we are also working on a few other bug
fixes and performance improvements as
needed at the post added problems thus
far don't tend to be too severe or game
breaking though we heavily suggest
turning on variable refresh rate in your
consoles and tv settings if they support
it this smoother gameplay experience
goes a long way during hectic boss
fights
[Music]
if you were among the first batch of
people to reserve a steam deck last year
make sure you're checking your inbox
valve is sending out final confirmation
emails today and you'll only have 72
hours to complete your purchase
otherwise it'll be passed to the next
person in line emails began going out
around 10 am pacific 1 pm eastern and
once it arrives you'll be able to make
your final payment confirm your shipping
details and barring any delays likely
get your hands on steam deck next week
steam deck might finally be on its way
to consumers but the official dock for
steam deck is still in development the
dock will let you easily connect your
steam deck to an external display and it
also has usb ports for peripherals that
said you can connect the steam deck to a
monitor or a tv without the dock despite
the steam deck not quite out yet there
are reportedly already discussions of a
steam deck 2. co-founder gabe newell
spoke to edge magazine about the next
iteration of steam deck and how it will
be more about its mobile pc capabilities
that you can't get through a desktop or
a laptop how do you feel about another
steam deck in the works already let me
know in the comments
for all of the deep rock galactic fans
out there the game is celebrating its
four-year anniversary with a big in-game
event and live stream from now until
march 7th you can play a brand new
assignment that will score you some new
hats balloons and free beers there will
also be a live stream celebration all
day on the ghost ship games twitch
channel if you want to get a behind the
scenes look at the past 4 years of deep
rock and to top it all off the game will
be free to play all weekend long for
those who haven't had a chance to try it
out rockin stone
now that everyone can officially play
eldon ring what do you think of it so
far give us your personal review in the
comments and before you go leave a like
subscribe and have a wonderful weekend
[Music]
you